[Music]
[Applause]
your screen
is currently filling up with clouds of
an algae that resembles
a unicellular flagellate known as
chlamydomonas
though we're not quite sure that that's
definitely what it is
the algae are swimming towards the lit
part of the stage and as they amass
they form a blanket over the slide that
looks like a kind of
very festive green television static
meanwhile on the more orderly end of
things we have this volvox
it's much larger than the tiny algae we
just saw
and it's also much more serene just a
nice
chill green ball in the middle of your
screen
it doesn't seem to have much in common
with the chlamydomonas i mean
yes they've got some green in common but
that's not particularly difficult to
come by in the microcosmos
but these two organisms are both part of
the same
family of algae called vulvacin algae
and when you look at a more extended
family portrait
maybe you will start to see the
resemblance you've got your gonium
looking like several of those little
green algae stuck together
and then there's this active pandora
also packing together several green
cells in its colony body as it moves
around
and then we see the eudarina and then
the pleodorina
which looks increasingly like the
orderly sphere
of the volvox in fact this combination
of footage
feels less like a family portrait and
more
like a series of yearbook photos taken
from kindergarten through senior year
except instead of the striking passage
of time
documented through the changing of a
child's face
this is the striking passage of
multicellular evolution
documented through the changes in one
algal family multicellularity
is one of those things that is so
entwined
with notions of complexity and the
forward marching of evolution that it
might feel
like it has to be one of those singular
evolutionary events
a moment that occurred once or maybe
twice
and was maybe too difficult to ever
replicate again
it turns out that making the jump from
unicellular to multicellular life
has actually happened quite a few times
in our planet's history it's maybe
surprisingly
not that difficult to transition but
finding a way to study it
is
many of these jumps happened too long
ago
and evolution has removed the organisms
whose bodies contain the story of how
they or their ancestors went from living
on their own
to teaming up with others but
fortunately the volvo scene algae went
about this transition
much more recently likely around 200
million years ago
and that leaves us with a gradient of
cellular complexity that starts
with the unicellular chlamydomonas
transitions to the colonial gatherings
of cells that make up the gonium through
the pleiadirino
and then leads us to the multicellular
volvox
that ordering though is a little
misleading in its simplicity
evolution isn't nearly so neat to work
in a straight line across a whole family
but
laying out the organisms in this way
helps us to understand that
steps are involved in taking the species
from unicellular to multicellular one of
the most apparent differences when we
compare those single-celled algae to
volvox
is how much bigger the volvox is the
world
is made up of large unicellular
organisms and small multicellular
organisms but in this family
there is an increase in size that is
connected
to how many cells an individual contains
so how to do that
vulvocine algae primarily reproduce
asexually
but where many microbes divide through
binary fission
dividing into two daughter cells that
then grow and divide again most
vulvasine algae
are a little more chaotic they divide
through
multiple fission which means that any
cell that's going to reproduce
starts by growing a lot
if they want two daughter cells they
grow twice as big if they want to make
four
they grow four times as large and once
they get as big as they need to the
algae
goes through a rapid series of divisions
to produce all those daughter cells in
quick succession
for chlamydomonas you might get around
four to eight daughter cells
a ghonium colony might have 8 to 16 and
with volvox
you can end up with thousands
and more than just the sheer increase in
numbers is what the daughter cells
do when they are newly made and the
chlamydomonas
algae they separate completely through a
process
called cytokinesis becoming their own
individual self
but with the colonial algae and on up
that cytokinesis is incomplete
leaving the cells connected
those connections are further supported
by an extracellular matrix
made up of glycoprotein and as the
number of cells
increased through evolution so too did
the volume of that matrix
at certain points in a volvox's life
cycle that transparent scaffolding
can make up 99 percent of its volume
but multicellular is more than just
getting big
the big step to taking the vulvasine
algae from
colony to multicellular life involves
putting all those cells to work
specialized work you can see the early
days of specialization
in the colonial algae through the
development of
organismal polarity which is a fancy way
of saying that we can define
a front and back of the colony the cells
in
front are generally large with big eye
spots
and as you go to the back the cells and
eye spots get smaller
these differences create a gradient not
just in characteristics
but in function the larger eye spots in
front
mean those cells will be more sensitive
to light making them
responsible for directing the colony
with the volvox
this specialization transforms into a
full division of labor
that you can actually see reflected in
the cells themselves
its globe-like shape features thousands
of tiny cells dotting the exterior
all orbiting a few large cells held in
the middle
those are two distinct cell types
the thousands of cells on the outside
are somatic cells
decorated with flagella to help the
organism move around
and there may be thousands of these
somatic cells but they can't
do the most important thing an organism
needs to do
which is reproduce instead that role
is given to those large cells called
ganidia
at some point in the volvox's life those
ganidia will each divide
to produce a new volvox which is
essential
to keeping the volvox lineage going the
one thing the gunnardia cannot do
is swim they don't have the flagella for
it
and that's why they need somatic cells
it is a full division of labor one that
you'll find
in many forms of multicellular organisms
all over the planet
but why why go through all of this
there's a lot of possible answers but
one of the simplest answers
is probably captured by this tardigrade
idly grazing on algae
looking a bit more like a water cow than
a water bear
here this chlamydomonas algae does not
stand a chance
but you know who does stand a chance a
pandora
it's simply too large to get into the
tardigrade's mouth
and in this moment hundreds of millions
of years of evolution
of cells dividing of being held together
through incomplete cytokinesis of
biologically defining front and back all
of that
comes together to save this little guy's
life
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us we have some very
exciting news
to share with you you know that unseen
world i just mentioned
well we want to help you see that world
and share it with us and with others
we've worked together with our master of
microscopes james weiss
to design a microscope with content
creation
in mind and you can now help us
make that microscope through a
kickstarter
we want people to be able to easily film
photograph and share their discoveries
with the world
so we are creating a microscope designed
to interface with the amazing cameras
that we all have in our pockets these
days we're going to be doing this
through a kickstarter campaign so if you
would like to help us make these
microscopes a reality
and get one of your own you will need to
visit the link in the description and
pledge
during the dates you're seeing on your
screen right now we're also creating
some materials to help
you in your journey into becoming a
microscopist
because of course using the microscope
is one part
but also you've got collecting samples
keeping them healthy
identifying what you're seeing finding
the right microscope
can be complicated and expensive and we
want to help with that
so it's as easy as possible for you to
start your own journey
if you're interested in picking one up
or if you just want to know more
details about the microscope itself you
can head on over
to the link in the description thank you
as always to all the people on screen
right now
they are our patrons on patreon and they
are as always the ones who have enabled
us
to go on this journey so if you like it
these are the people to thank
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you